a woman accused of abducting her son in
a case that drew international attention
is speaking out in her first u.s.
interview we first told you about Marcel
Equis mariah's more than three years ago
the Houston mother took her son Nico to
Brazil in 2013 and never returned she's
charged with international parental
kidnapping Nico's father has been
fighting to bring the little boy back to
Texas and now her parents face
sentencing on a kidnapping charge for
helping their daughter take their now
nine-year-old boy to Brazil Marcelino
Benito of our Houston affiliate that's
KHOU spoke with guam arias outside he is
outside the federal courthouse in
Houston Marcelino good morning to you
good morning Marsalis parents are facing
up to three years in federal prison when
they're sentenced later today speaking
to us from Brazil Marcela says she had
no choice but to leave that this was a
life in death situation Marcela guima
rise is a fugitive wanted by the FBI for
kidnapping her son Nico in 2013 and
taking him to Brazil but in her first
u.s. interview we mariah's told us she's
the real victim these photos taken
inside the home she once shared with her
ex-husband Christopher bran show the
holes he punched into the walls in fits
of anger in this 2012 email to Gwynn
Mariah's bran admits to pushing her onto
the bed and floor and hitting her face
will rise as parents Carlos and Jimena
pointed to the alleged domestic-violence
at their criminal trial in May but the
jury rejected that defense and found
them guilty of international parental
kidnapping the couple were accused of
helping Wimmer eyes by securing her job
in Brazil and enrolling Nico in a school
there before their daughter fled
certainly we had a very difficult
relationship bran a doctor in Houston
says although his marriage was volatile
US and Brazilian authorities have
repeatedly discredited groom arises
abuse claims he says he only hit her in
self-defense I was not an aggressor and
I was not abusing her physically bran
hopes his former in-laws will get the
stiffest sentence possible 27 to 33
months in prison to discourage parental
abduction cases in the future this story
is about the relationship that I have
with my boy and how that's been
destroyed by this family
Marcela's parents say it's unfair to
hold them responsible for their
daughter's actions in that they have no
real way of forcing her to come back to
the United States as for dr. Brandis
been to Brazil several times but has not
been back since February he claims if he
returns he'll be arrested there for
unpaid child support
bianna Marcelino with that exclusive
interview thank you